So the g 20 was in Japan just a few days ago.
Donald Trump was there and before heading
to the North Korean DMZ.
But also with him was Ivanka Trump, Trump's
daughter, who of course legally can't officially
be a part of Donald Trump's administration
due to anti-nepotism laws.
But this hasn't stopped her from showing up
all sorts of places that she has no business
being.
And now a video has been released, which I'm
going to play for you from the g 20 where
Ivanka Trump is speaking with some world leaders.
She's in a circle, small circle with Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau, French President
Emmanuel Macron, British Prime Minister Theresa
May, and head of the IMF, the International
Monetary Fund, Christine La Guard, and Ivanka
Trump is there.
So right away there is a question like, what
the hell is Ivanka Trump doing there?
And this is very visual.
So if you're listening to this on the radio
or to the audio podcast, find either our youtube
clip or the video is widely available because
you really need to see it to fully understand
it.
The world leaders look physically in pain.
When Ivanka Trump tries to talk.
Christine Lagarde looks so disgusted that
Trump's daughter is part of this discussion
that she doesn't even look over at Ivanka
when Ivanka starts saying things and then
you will see the look on Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau's phase.
I don't know how to describe it other than
pained, and then you will see the look on
Emmanuel macrons face, which is I guess what
you would call a knowing smirk of some kind
that he seems to be sharing with the other
world leaders heads up.
This is not safe for kids.
Okay.
This is not safe for work.
This is so cringy that I recommend pulling
all the kids out of the room right away before
we play it because this is so, so viral.
Let's take a look at it.
[inaudible] as soon as you start from that
aspect, a lot of people start listening.
You wouldn't otherwise listen
in terms of [inaudible],
this family is embarrassing.
The United States around the world.
Everyone in this group of world leaders is
wondering, what the hell is Ivanka Trump doing
here?
Nepotism.
Barbie there along with her father, the mango
menace.
And by the way, huge, huge, huge props to
the French government for releasing this video
because this video is a public service.
It's one of those a presented without comment
things that just tells us everything we need
know without actually having to say anything
about it.
Being Donald Trump's daughter is no qualification
in the sense of, okay, she gets to have Trump's
company when Trump gives it up, if that's
what Trump wants, she gets Trump's money when
he gives it up or dies if that's what Trump
wants to do.
But you don't get to talk policy with world
leaders at the GE 20 or at least you shouldn't.
And if you're a Trump is defending this insanity.
Step back for a second and tell me what you'd
be saying if this was Chelsea Clinton doing
this as part of a Hillary Clinton presidency,
the outrage would be nonstop 24 seven on every
single conservative media outlet.
Even centrist corporate media would be hosting
debate after debate over whether this is okay
or not.
And also to every Trump just saying it's rude
for the world leaders to be ignoring Ivanka,
good for them, good for them.
This is like when you intern somewhere and
you work your way up as an employee for 10
years, and then the boss's daughter comes
in and now she's your manager and she's clueless.
Two years ago, Ivanka Trump was stealing shoe
designs from awkward Zuora and now she's talking
to prime ministers in Japan while her dad
further embarrasses himself to, to every right
winger who criticize, uh, criticizes or criticized
Alexandria Cossio Cortez for being quote just
a waitress before being a congresswoman.
You can agree with Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
on policy or disagree with her.
That's fine.
At least she earned the waitressing job herself
as opposed to it being handed to her by her
family.
We're in serious trouble here.
We're in a very, very serious,
it's trouble here.
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Instagram at David Dot.
Pacman.
The show is on Instagram at David Pakman show,
the
David Pakman show